This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Summer is normally cruise ship season in Southeast Alaska. Every year around this time, these floating behemoths filled with tourists sail up the inside passage, stopping at little coastal port towns like Sitka and Ketchikan. One of the popular destinations along the route is Glacier Bay. It's this spectacular bay full of glaciers and the name and icebergs and sea otters and lots and lots of humpback whales. The National Park Service regulates how many cruise ships can come in and out of the
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在阿拉斯加东南部，夏季通常是游轮航季。每年这个时候，这些载满游客的庞然大物都会沿着内航道航行，停靠在锡特卡和凯奇坎等沿海小镇。航线上最受欢迎的目的地之一是冰川湾。这是一个壮观的海湾，到处都是冰川、冰山、海獭，还有许许多多座头鲸。国家公园管理局对进出海湾的游轮数量以及它们靠近鲸鱼的距离都有严格规定。
bay and how close they can get to the whales. But still, the humpbacks that are there in the summer have to live alongside roaring boat engines. What we know is that animals change their behavior when the ocean gets noisy. Michelle Forne is an acoustic ecologist at Cornell. Every summer she travels to Glacier Bay to drop a hydrophone in the water, listening in on what the whales are saying, and study how it's being affected by ship noise. This year, Michelle was preparing for her annual trip to Alaska when the COVID-19 shutdowns were announced.
但即便如此，夏天待在那里的座头鲸仍不得不与震耳欲聋的船只引擎声共存。我们已知的是，当海洋变得嘈杂时，动物会改变它们的行为。米歇尔·福恩是康奈尔大学的一名声学生态学家。每年夏天，她都会前往冰川湾，将水听器放入水中，监听鲸鱼的交流，并研究它们如何受到船只噪音的影响。今年，米歇尔正准备前往阿拉斯加进行年度考察时，新冠疫情封锁的消息传来了。
So, Friday, the 13th was the last day that we were allowed to be in the lab at work before we had to start sheltering in place. And what that also meant for my perspective was that my summer field season was canceled, that the trip to Alaska that I was meant to take to go and do work with these animals wasn't going to happen. The lab at Cornell would also need to close, and so all the scientists gathered together
所以，13号星期五是我们被要求居家隔离前，最后一天获准在实验室工作。从我的角度来看，这也意味着我的夏季实地考察季被取消了，我原本计划去阿拉斯加与这些动物一起工作的行程泡汤了。康奈尔大学的实验室也必须关闭，所以所有的科学家聚在一起，
for a final in-person meeting to try to plan out how everyone was going to keep their research going from home. And Michelle mentioned that the summer cruise season would probably not even happen this year in Alaska, at which point another person at the meeting broke in with a question. And one of my colleagues and friends looked at me and she asked me, you know, are you listening? In other words, even if she couldn't go to see the whales in person, what she's still planning on listening to them? And I realized I wasn't.
开了最后一次面对面的会议，试图规划每个人如何在家继续他们的研究。米歇尔提到，今年阿拉斯加的夏季游轮航季可能根本不会出现，这时会议上的另一个人插话问了一个问题。我的一位同事兼朋友看着我问我：“你知道吗，你在倾听吗？”换句话说，即使她不能亲自去见鲸鱼，她是否仍计划倾听它们的声音？我意识到我并没有。
And all of a sudden, my personal sentimental brain turned off and my biologist brain turned back on and an immediate flurry to get hydrophones in the water ensued. In that moment, Michelle realized that although her research trip had been canceled, the coronavirus shutdown had created an incredible opportunity. For the first time in decades, the ocean would be quiet for an entire summer.
突然之间，我感性的大脑关闭了，生物学家的大脑重新启动，随后便是一阵忙乱，试图将水听器放入水中。那一刻，米歇尔意识到，尽管她的研究行程被取消了，但新冠疫情的封锁却创造了一个绝佳的机会。几十年来，海洋第一次迎来了一个完整的安静夏天。
And so what that means for somebody like me as researcher is that we have the opportunity to listen to undisturbed behavior for the first time. Usually Michelle relies on quiet periods in an individual day to try to understand how ship noise changes whale behavior. I get excited when we have six or seven hours of silence in the ocean. I built an entire dissertation around the fact
对于像我这样的研究人员来说，这意味着我们第一次有机会倾听不受干扰的行为。通常，米歇尔依赖于一天中安静的时段来试图理解船只噪音如何改变鲸鱼的行为。当我们有六七个小时的海洋寂静时，我会感到兴奋。我整个博士论文都是围绕着这样一个事实建立的：
that Glacier Bay is one of the few areas in the world where you can predictably have moments of silence. And now what we have is months of silence. So this is unheard of. Right after that final meeting at the lab, Michelle started calling people in Alaska who could help her out. I had to call my best friend because all of my gear lives in her garage and could she blow up some booze for me and tie some line for me. And if I could put a hydrophone in the mail would she be willing to attach it to a shackle and then pass it off to someone else to put
冰川湾是世界上为数不多的可以预见会有寂静时刻的地区之一。而现在，我们拥有了数月的寂静。这简直闻所未闻。在实验室的最后一次会议结束后，米歇尔立即开始联系阿拉斯加那些能帮上忙的人。我不得不给最好的朋友打电话，因为我所有的装备都放在她的车库里，她能帮我给浮标充气并系好绳子吗？如果我能把水听器寄过去，她愿意把它系在卸扣上，然后转交给别人，
it on an anchor who would then get it onto a boat and drop it in the ocean. Eventually with the help of lots of people in Alaska they got hydrophones into the water. Michelle is now set to record an entire summer of whale sounds, in strangely quiet seas. This is the first time in human history that we've been able to listen to truly quiet behavior. Which is something that the researchers could have never engineered on their own. Michelle's hypothesis is that the complexity of interactions between whales will go up.
把它装在锚上，再由人把它放到船上，最后投入海中。最终，在阿拉斯加许多人的帮助下，他们成功将水听器放入了水中。米歇尔现在准备在异常安静的海域记录整个夏天的鲸鱼声音。这是人类历史上第一次能够倾听真正安静的行为，这是研究人员靠自己永远无法设计出来的。米歇尔的假设是，鲸鱼之间互动的复杂性将会提高。
So if you think about having a conversation in a really loud room, let's say you're at a bar and you're trying to talk to someone. You're going to talk louder and you're going to talk higher and you're going to use pretty simple words to make sure that you're understood. But if you're sitting at home having a cup of tea on your couch and there's no music playing and it's quiet and you're talking to someone who's beloved to you, the nature of the conversation can get really nuanced. So that's one of the things that we'd like to find out with these humpbacks is when they're not struggling to
所以，如果你想象在一个非常吵闹的房间里进行对话，比如你在酒吧里试图和某人交谈。你会说得更大声，音调更高，并且会使用非常简单的词汇以确保对方能听懂。但如果你坐在家里，在沙发上喝着茶，没有音乐播放，环境安静，而且你正在和心爱的人交谈，对话的本质就会变得非常微妙。所以，这就是我们想通过这些座头鲸发现的事情之一：当它们不再挣扎着
be heard, does the complexity of what they say increase? Are they willing and able to have more nuanced acoustic interactions that perhaps they can't have when it's noisy? But whatever happens, Michelle is just excited to dig into the data. We will finally get a baseline for what the ocean sounds like in the absence of human activity. In general, the coronavirus shutdowns have been terrible for academic research. Trips have been canceled. Labs have shut down and long-running experiments have been interrupted, but there are some researchers like Michelle,
被听到时，它们交流的复杂性会增加吗？它们是否愿意并能够进行更微妙的声学互动，而这些互动在嘈杂的环境中可能无法实现？但无论发生什么，米歇尔只是对挖掘数据感到兴奋。我们终于将获得一个基准，了解在没有人为活动的情况下海洋听起来是什么样的。总的来说，新冠疫情的封锁对学术研究来说是灾难性的。行程被取消，实验室关闭，长期进行的实验被迫中断，但像米歇尔这样的一些研究人员，
for whom the shutdowns have provided a unique opportunity. A whole new dataset, a chance to gather new information, or look at information in a new way. In science, the term natural experiment refers to an experiment that happens outside of the lab, and outside of the control of the experimenter. With the pandemic the world outside the lab has changed dramatically and it has affected all kinds of systems that can be measured for the first time in the modern era. So this week our producers
封锁为他们提供了一个独特的机会。一个全新的数据集，一个收集新信息或以新方式审视信息的机会。在科学领域，“自然实验”是指在实验室之外、在实验者控制之外发生的实验。随着疫情的爆发，实验室外的世界发生了巨大变化，它影响了各种系统，这些系统在现代史上第一次可以被测量。所以本周，我们的制作人
have brought us stories from very different fields about researchers who are using this tragic and bizarre moment to learn something new about the world. First up is producer Emmett Fitzgerald. Jalantara is a city in northern India, in the state of Punjab, and like all Indian cities Jalantara has been in lockdown with everybody inside their homes. But a couple of weeks ago, there was this bright sunny day
为我们带来了来自不同领域的故事，讲述了研究人员如何利用这个悲剧性且离奇的时刻来了解关于世界的新事物。首先是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。贾朗达尔是印度北部旁遮普邦的一座城市，像所有印度城市一样，贾朗达尔一直处于封锁状态，每个人都待在家里。但几周前，那是一个明媚的晴天，
and the residents of the city went out onto their roofs. And what they saw was this amazing view of the snow-capped Himalayas, which are about 100 miles away. And this view was celebrated like all over Indian social media. There are tons of pictures of these mountains on Instagram and TikTok videos of people zooming in on the horizon. So why was this such a big deal? Well because many people were seeing these mountains for the very first time.
城市居民走上了屋顶。他们看到了令人惊叹的雪山景观，那是约100英里外的喜马拉雅山。这一景象在印度社交媒体上广为流传。Instagram上有大量这些山脉的照片，TikTok上也有人们放大地平线的视频。那么，为什么这会引起如此大的轰动呢？因为许多人是第一次看到这些山脉。
People who had lived in Gelandar all their lives had suddenly woken up to this vista of snow-capped mountains across the horizon. A view that they said that they had never seen before. This is Rago Karnad, and he wrote about this phenomenon for the New Yorker. And he says that because of air pollution, the mountains have been completely obscured. Locals, I think, the last time these mountains had been visible was about 30 years ago. But because of the shutdown and the lack of pollution from cars and industry, the skies were clear in a way that had seemed impossible before.
在贾朗达尔生活了一辈子的人们突然醒来，看到了地平线上白雪皑皑的山脉。他们说这是他们从未见过的景象。这是拉格·卡纳德，他为《纽约客》撰写了关于这一现象的文章。他说，由于空气污染，这些山脉一直被完全遮挡。当地人认为，这些山脉上一次可见大约是在30年前。但由于封锁以及汽车和工业污染的减少，天空变得前所未有的清澈。
That was the kind of scope of the transformation that had made the unimaginable real. And so was this phenomenon unique to Jolanda? Yeah, I mean, I think it's a particularly dramatic and poetic example, but really in cities all across India, the sky is blue and you can see the stars at night, the air feels clean in a way that it just hasn't in a really long time. And you know, air pollution is a huge problem in India. Of the 20 cities in the world, but the worst air pollution, 14 of them are Indian cities.
这就是那种让不可想象变为现实的变革规模。那么，这种现象是贾朗达尔独有的吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个特别戏剧性和诗意的例子，但实际上在印度各地的城市，天空是蓝色的，晚上可以看到星星，空气感觉非常干净，这在很长一段时间里都没有发生过。而且你知道，空气污染在印度是一个巨大的问题。世界上空气污染最严重的20个城市中，有14个是印度城市。
You really can't exaggerate it. India is the global hotspot for air pollution, 14 of them are Indian cities. You really can't exaggerate it. India is the global hotspot for air pollution, and that's happened. We've sort of taken that place from China over the last 20 years. And one of the cities with the worst air quality is the capital city, Delhi. Karnat has lived there for a lot of his adult life.
你真的无法夸大它。印度是全球空气污染的热点地区，其中14个是印度城市。你真的无法夸大它。印度是全球空气污染的热点地区，这种情况已经发生了。在过去的20年里，我们从中国手中接过了这个位置。空气质量最差的城市之一是首都德里。卡纳德在那里度过了他成年生活的大部分时间。
And he told me that a part of his morning routine would be to check a website that maps the air quality index throughout the city. And just for context, when AQI is over 300, it's considered hazardous to your health. But Cronon said that he would sometimes see readings of 999. And the reason it was that figure, 999, was not because that was the correct reading. It's because that's where the monitors maxed out. Even if you're a writer, it feels like language is failing you. You kind of describe it to yourself, you say, oh God, this is a nightmare. This is a sci-fi movie. This is like the apocalypse.
他告诉我，他早晨例行公事的一部分就是查看一个绘制全市空气质量指数的网站。作为背景，当AQI超过300时，被认为对健康有害。但卡纳德说，他有时会看到999的读数。而之所以是999这个数字，并不是因为这是正确的读数，而是因为那是监测仪的上限。即使你是一名作家，也会觉得语言匮乏。你试图向自己描述它，你说，天哪，这是一场噩梦。这是一部科幻电影。这就像世界末日。
And none of that helps you comprehend the fact that there's small, visible inside your home. That's incredible. Not seeing a mountain is one thing, but this is just a gigantic public health tragedy. Totally. I think air pollution is really one of the most underappreciated public health problems that we have. The WHO says that 4.6 million people die each year from causes related to air pollution. And that's happening all over the world, but it really is most dire in India.
而这些都无法让你理解你的家中竟然有可见的微粒。这太不可思议了。看不到山是一回事，但这简直是一场巨大的公共卫生悲剧。完全正确。我认为空气污染确实是我们面临的最被低估的公共卫生问题之一。世界卫生组织称，每年有460万人死于与空气污染相关的原因。这种情况发生在世界各地，但在印度确实最为严峻。
The World Health Organization had an estimate from 2016 that 100,000 Indian children below the age of five had died that year from exposure to a particular kind of particulates in air pollution. And the figures make it quite abundantly clear that Indians are dying and being made sick in really vast numbers, numbers that are almost sort of too large to process. And you know, for years, it's felt so large, like such a large problem that it's almost unsolvable. And that's what makes this moment so extraordinary, which is that we've reached this solution. We've fixed this problem without intending to.
世界卫生组织2016年的一项估计显示，那一年有10万名五岁以下的印度儿童死于接触空气污染中的特定微粒。这些数字非常清楚地表明，印度人正在大量死亡和患病，这些数字大到几乎无法处理。而且你知道，多年来，它感觉如此巨大，像是一个几乎无法解决的问题。而这正是让这一刻如此非凡的原因，因为我们无意中找到了解决方案。我们解决了这个问题。
That is incredible. I mean, it really does like create this strange, sober lining to an international tragedy. Yeah, and I think people are reluctant to use language like that because it's obviously such a terrible situation, but there's one group of people for whom this shutdown really has been a gift, and that's air pollution researchers. Researchers like Sarath Guti-Kwenda. I'm Shalath Guti-Kwenda. I'm the director and the founder of Urban Emissions. Urban Emissions is an independent research group and we do research on evolution.
这太不可思议了。我的意思是，它确实为一场国际悲剧带来了一线奇怪而清醒的希望。是的，我认为人们不愿使用那样的语言，因为这显然是一个非常糟糕的情况，但有一群人，这次封锁确实是一份礼物，那就是空气污染研究人员。像萨拉特·古蒂昆达这样的研究人员。我是萨拉特·古蒂昆达。我是“城市排放”组织的创始人和主任。“城市排放”是一个独立的研究小组，我们从事空气污染研究。
And the scientists that Urban Emissions are always looking to understand the baseline, air quality, like what would a clean air scenario even look like. And usually they use holidays when people are stuck inside or rainy days to do this But those don't last very long when it rains it's clean for one day and then the never-ending next day the build-up starts happening But what we are seeing here is sustained for a sustained period of time. We are seeing low numbers So good t kunda says that the shutdown feels like the entire country is basically running a giant experiment for him.
“城市排放”的科学家们一直在寻求了解基准空气质量，比如清洁空气的场景会是什么样子。通常他们利用人们待在室内的假期或雨天来进行研究，但这些时间持续不长。下雨时，空气会干净一天，然后第二天污染又开始积聚。但我们在这里看到的是持续了一段时间。我们看到了低数值。所以古蒂昆达说，封锁对他来说就像整个国家基本上在进行一场巨大的实验。
The phrase that I've been using is forced experiment. It's a forced experiment that shows you what happens if you turn many of the major sources of pollution down basically to zero. And when you do that, turns out the air is pretty clean, which might seem obvious, but the air pollution problem has been so intractable in India, and here is this concrete example showing that it's possible to clean up the air. So, if you have an example of a sustained period, we're saying, when we can maintain
我一直在用的词是“强制实验”。这是一个强制实验，它向你展示了如果你将许多主要的污染源基本降至零会发生什么。当你这样做时，结果证明空气非常干净，这看起来可能很明显，但空气污染问题在印度一直难以解决，而这里有一个具体的例子表明清洁空气是可能的。所以，如果你有一个持续一段时间的例子，我们说，当我们能够维持
this level of emissions, and this is the kind of a quality we're saying, we can maintain this level of emissions and this is the kind of equality we're going to experience. And, you know, having this extended period of clean air is also allowing them to do more fine-tuned research experiments. Some of those are really chemistry, looking at particular pollutants like ozone, for example, and sort of tracking it. But they're also trying to do a forensic accounting of where all this air pollution is coming from.
这种排放水平，这就是我们所看到的空气质量，我们能够维持这种排放水平，这就是我们将体验到的空气质量。而且，你知道，拥有这段延长的清洁空气期也让他们能够进行更精细的研究实验。其中一些确实是化学研究，观察臭氧等特定污染物，并对其进行追踪。但他们也试图对所有这些空气污染的来源进行法医式的核算。
Because there's actually a lot of confusion about this in India, and a big question people have is like, is the pollution generated inside the city by things like cars and trash burning and dirty cook stoves? Or is it floating in from outside sources? From things like power plants and heavy industry outside the city, or farmers in the countryside who burn their fields before they replant? All those sources are contributing to the problem,
因为在印度，关于这一点实际上有很多困惑，人们的一个大问题是：污染是由城市内部的汽车、垃圾焚烧和肮脏的炉灶产生的吗？还是从外部来源漂浮进来的？来自城市外的发电厂和重工业，或者是在重新种植前焚烧田地的农村农民？所有这些来源都导致了这个问题，
but the uncertainty about who to blame has allowed cities to basically throw up their hands and say, this isn't a problem that we can solve. Right, so the uncertainty allows the people in power to just do essentially just pass the buck and not deal with it at all. Yeah, exactly. And so that's been one of the goals of Guti Kunda's research. Because certain sources of pollution have been completely turned off while others have carried on, Guti Kunda is able to isolate the different sources of emissions.
但关于该责怪谁的不确定性，使得城市基本上可以一摊手说，这不是我们能解决的问题。没错，所以这种不确定性让当权者可以推卸责任，根本不去处理它。是的，完全正确。这就是古蒂昆达研究的目标之一。由于某些污染源被完全关闭，而其他污染源仍在继续，古蒂昆达能够分离出不同的排放源。
And calculate, you and calculate how much of the pollution that a city is experiencing is generated inside of the city itself. And it turns out, it's a lot. We can easily see a lot chunk of it actually coming from the local sources. City like Delhi, we find that the easily 70% of the pollution is actually locally generated. So just so I understand, normally, a city like Delhi would sort of blame the pollution on outside forces, saying this is coming from power plants outside the city, or this is coming from agricultural burning, and the reality is Delhi is responsible for a lot of Delhi's pollution problem.
并计算出城市所经历的污染中有多少是由城市自身产生的。结果发现，比例很高。我们可以清楚地看到很大一部分实际上来自本地来源。像德里这样的城市，我们发现至少70%的污染实际上是本地产生的。所以为了确保我理解正确，通常像德里这样的城市会把污染归咎于外部力量，说这是来自城市外的发电厂，或者是来自农业焚烧，而现实是德里要为德里大部分的污染问题负责。
Absolutely. Now, a lot of this research is just confirming what the scientists at Urban Emissions had really been seeing in their models before. But Raghav Karnad says that, you know, because that analysis was based on more hypothetical modeling, policymakers were finding it much easier to reject and ignore. Now, they have data that confirms exactly what their models have been demonstrating, which is that cities can do much more to fix their own problem and to clean up their own house. And the biggest thing that a city like Delhi could do to clean up its own house is really to take on traffic.
绝对是这样。现在，这项研究中的很多内容只是证实了“城市排放”的科学家们在模型中真正看到的情况。但拉格·卡纳德说，你知道，因为该分析是基于更假设性的建模，政策制定者发现拒绝和忽视它要容易得多。现在，他们有了确凿的数据，证实了他们的模型所展示的内容，即城市可以做更多的事情来解决自己的问题，清理自己的门户。而像德里这样的城市能做的清理门户的最大事情，确实是解决交通问题。
Right, which can be a pretty hard problem solve unless you're willing to take pretty drastic measures and change the nature of a city. Yeah, and Daley has tried to do something about cars in the past. For example, they have tried one of those odds and evens policies where people with an odd last digit on their license plate can drive on some days and then even last digits can drive on the others. But it hasn't always been easy to convince people that policies like that are worth it. So that's why the specificity and the credibility of this data is so important. You really need to be able to back up your policy plans and the policy plans
没错，这可能是一个很难解决的问题，除非你愿意采取非常激进的措施并改变城市的性质。是的，德里过去曾尝试过处理汽车问题。例如，他们尝试过那种单双号限行政策，车牌最后一位是奇数的人可以在某些日子开车，而偶数的人可以在其他日子开车。但要说服人们这种政策是值得的并不总是那么容易。这就是为什么这些数据的具体性和可信度如此重要。你确实需要能够支持你的政策计划，而政策计划
need to be very comprehensive and they need to be very convincing because a lot of people maybe put out of work or are severely inconvenienced by the kind of changes that we need to we need to see. But you know cities have cleaned up their air before it's possible Beijing for example used to have the worst air quality in the world but then that became something of an embarrassment when they were chosen to host the Olympics in 2008. Right, right, you can't have that. It's like a huffing and puffing the most toxic hair in the world. Like for days and days on end, yeah. Right, right. And so they put in, you know, all these really intense restrictions to clean up the air in time for the games. The Olympics took a place, and when they were done done all those restrictions were lifted and very quickly the air went back to being as bad as it had been before but but
需要非常全面且具有说服力，因为很多人可能会失业，或者因为我们需要看到的变革而受到严重的不便。但你知道，城市以前也清理过空气，这是可能的。例如，北京曾经拥有世界上最差的空气质量，但当他们被选中举办2008年奥运会时，这成了一件令人尴尬的事情。没错，没错，你不能那样。这就像是呼吸着世界上最毒的空气。连续好几天，是的。没错，没错。所以他们实施了所有这些非常严格的限制措施，以便在奥运会前清理空气。奥运会举行了，当它们结束后，所有这些限制都被取消了，空气很快又变得像以前一样糟糕，但是
now people were unhappy about it. What had seemed impossible to ask for had proven to be possible to deliver which was blue skies and clean air and to not live in the most polluted city in the world, which was what Beijing was. So now there was a public outcry. And the city responded to that public outcry. Beijing tightened emission standards on trucks, subsidized electric cars, they regulated traffic in congested areas and built a giant bike share program. They closed coal fire power plants and encouraged residents to stop burning coal inside their homes.
现在人们对此感到不满了。曾经被认为不可能的要求已被证明是可以实现的，那就是蓝天和清洁空气，并且不再生活在世界上污染最严重的城市，这就是北京曾经的样子。所以现在出现了公众抗议。城市对这种公众抗议做出了回应。北京收紧了卡车的排放标准，补贴电动汽车，规范了拥堵地区的交通，并建立了巨大的共享单车计划。他们关闭了燃煤电厂，并鼓励居民停止在室内烧煤。
12 years later, Beijing is nowhere on the list of the worst polluted cities in the world. I don't even believe that it's in the top 100. So the example of the Beijing Olympics doesn't just demonstrate that it is possible to improve there, but it also demonstrates that people once they've experienced that it's doable, will want that and can be moved to demand that. Do you have hope that something similar could happen in India? As with a lot of things right now, I hope is not negotiable, but it's never felt more possible that
12年后，北京在世界上污染最严重的城市名单中已经销声匿迹了。我甚至不相信它在前100名之内。所以北京奥运会的例子不仅证明了改善空气质量是可能的，而且还证明了人们一旦体验到这是可行的，就会想要它，并可以被推动去要求它。你对印度也能发生类似的事情抱有希望吗？和现在很多事情一样，希望不是可以商量的，但它从未像现在这样让人觉得
Indian cities could be livable, sane and even healthy. And so we've just got a hope that everyone can be brought around to realizing the necessity of this collective action, just the way everyone has been brought around to realizing that with coronavirus. I mean, do you think it's interesting that, you know, we've seen people make the decision that, you know, COVID-19 is a threat to public health that is so severe that we need to take these extremely severe actions. Like, what is it about that that's different than air pollution?
印度城市是可以居住、理智甚至健康的。所以我们只能希望每个人都能意识到这种集体行动的必要性，就像每个人都意识到新冠病毒的必要性一样。我的意思是，你不觉得很有趣吗，我们看到人们做出决定，新冠疫情是对公共健康的严重威胁，以至于我们需要采取这些极其严厉的行动。那么，这与空气污染有什么不同呢？
You know, like, if it about that that's different than air pollution? You know, like if the numbers show that air pollution is also a public health crisis, like what about a virus is easier to sort of wrap your head around as a public health problem than air pollution? I think that's a fascinating question and I think that it's something well worth investigating what it was that made us capable of this really inspiring robust collective sacrifice that made us capable of this determination to transform our lives and escape this crisis just with the coronavirus. When in fact our cities have been in a state of crisis for a long time. They have been practically unlivable and frankly unbearable for a long time, and it
你知道，如果数据显示空气污染也是一场公共卫生危机，那么病毒有什么更容易让人理解为公共卫生问题的地方吗？我认为这是一个引人入胜的问题，我认为非常值得调查是什么让我们能够做出这种真正鼓舞人心的、强有力的集体牺牲，是什么让我们能够下定决心改变生活并摆脱这场危机，就像对待新冠病毒一样。而事实上，我们的城市长期以来一直处于危机状态。它们长期以来几乎无法居住，坦率地说难以忍受，而且
never moved us to anything like this kind of collective effort. I mean, as a society, we just process different types of risks so differently. I mean, if we were just looking at the raw numbers of deaths, we would never get into a car again. Right. And just to be clear, the point, I don't think is that we're overreacting to COVID-19. It's that we're underreacting to all
它从未促使我们进行任何类似这种集体努力的事情。我的意思是，作为一个社会，我们处理不同类型风险的方式太不同了。我的意思是，如果我们只看死亡的原始数字，我们就永远不会再坐进汽车里了。没错。为了清楚起见，我认为重点不是我们对新冠疫情反应过度。而是我们对所有
these other public health threats. In part, I would say I would argue because many of them have disproportionate impacts on poor people and people of color, especially air pollution. If you have money and you live in a city like Delhi, you can take an Uber from your air condition department to your air condition office job. But there are millions of people who can't afford to do that,
这些其他公共卫生威胁反应不足。在某种程度上，我会说，我会争辩说，因为其中许多对穷人和有色人种有不成比例的影响，尤其是空气污染。如果你有钱，住在像德里这样的城市，你可以从有空调的公寓坐优步去有空调的办公室工作。但有数百万人负担不起这样做，
who ride their bike or walk to get around, shop and open air markets, those people are just breathing the air all the time. I mean, it's so it's also just like an environmental justice issue. Yeah, yeah, it's a huge environmental justice issue. And for my mind, just like the best example of a underappreciated public health threat. Yeah, I think that probably climate change is also another pretty good example of that too. Totally, totally. I've been thinking about climate change is also another pretty good example of that too. Totally.
他们骑自行车或步行出行，在露天市场购物，这些人一直在呼吸那种空气。我的意思是，这同样也是一个环境正义问题。是的，是的，这是一个巨大的环境正义问题。在我看来，这就像是一个被低估的公共卫生威胁的最佳例子。是的，我认为气候变化可能也是另一个很好的例子。完全正确，完全正确。我一直在思考气候变化可能也是另一个很好的例子。完全正确。
I've been thinking about climate change a lot lately. I'm always thinking about climate change, but particularly now, in part because, like coronavirus, it's a problem that just demands collective global action. And Raghunkaran, that's the thing about climate change a lot to these days. Yeah, absolutely. And I don't want to make India sound special, but when it comes to climate change, we are in the front line because there are really parts of the country in the interior where the increased heat is making life unlivable.
我最近一直在思考气候变化。我一直在思考气候变化，但尤其是现在，部分原因是因为，像新冠病毒一样，这是一个需要集体全球行动的问题。拉格·卡纳德，这些天也一直在思考气候变化。是的，绝对是。我不想让印度听起来很特别，但当谈到气候变化时，我们处于前线，因为在内陆地区确实有一些地方，气温升高使得生活变得无法忍受。
If there's any country that should be confronting climate change as an emergency that we take on on a war footing as an emergency that makes anything possible and any measures acceptable, then this is that country. And just like the other crises, as you've mentioned, it's just never seemed justified. It's never seemed, it's never seemed justified to do something like this, not even for climate change. That is so remarkable. Yeah, and I guess like with climate change and with air pollution and with all this, I think this story in India really raises for me just kind of this question of like,
如果有什么国家应该把气候变化视为紧急情况，并以战时状态来应对，视为一种让一切皆有可能、任何措施都可以接受的紧急情况，那么这就是那个国家。就像其他危机一样，正如你所提到的，它似乎从未被证明是合理的。它从未看起来，它从未看起来有理由做这样的事情，即使是为了气候变化。这太引人注目了。是的，我想就像气候变化和空气污染以及所有这些一样，我认为这个在印度的故事确实为我提出了这样一个问题：
what are we going back to when we come out of all this and like, are we, are we, we don't want to talk about silver linings when so much bad is happening, but is are there things we can learn from the ways in which the world has been, has been changed by this moment, even in the weird ways in which it's been changed for the better? Totally. I don't think it diminishes the moment to treat the moment as having lessons for us in the future.
当我们走出这一切时，我们要回到什么地方？我们不想在发生这么多坏事时谈论一线希望，但我们能从世界被这一刻改变的方式中学到什么吗？即使是以它变得更好的奇怪方式？完全正确。我不认为把这一刻视为对未来有教训的时刻会削弱这一刻的意义。
I mean, I think that it would be, you know, a double tragedy if we went through this and learned nothing. So let's just take advantage of what we've learned about pandemics, about air pollution, about everything, and try to make the world better. Yeah, I think it's, I think it's all we can do. So we're now moving on to the next natural experiment which is presented by our producer Joe Rosenberg. Hey Joe. Hey there.
我的意思是，我认为如果我们经历了这一切却什么也没学到，那将是双重悲剧。所以让我们利用我们从大流行、空气污染、一切事物中学到的东西，努力让世界变得更好。是的，我认为这是我们唯一能做的。所以我们现在进入下一个自然实验，由我们的制作人乔·罗森伯格介绍。嘿，乔。嘿。
So it's time to your report. What kind of scientific study is on the precipice of advancement as an unexpected result of COVID-19? I'm so glad you asked because for the past few days I have been delving into the very latest research being done at the very cutting edge of an exciting highly specialized scientific field, boredom studies. Boredom studies. I mean, I guess everything is a thing, but I didn't know that was a thing.
所以是你的报道时间了。作为新冠疫情的一个意外结果，什么样的科学研究正处于进步的边缘？我很高兴你问这个问题，因为过去几天我一直在深入研究一个令人兴奋的高度专业化科学领域的最前沿研究：无聊研究。无聊研究。我的意思是，我猜万物皆可研究，但我不知道还有这个。
It is a thing, although even the boredom study experts themselves seem to be surprised that it is a thing and that they study it. No one, I think, has a little kid ever says, like, you know what I really want to do when I grow up? I want to study boredom. So it's certainly, it was totally unplanned. This is Erin Westgate. She's an assistant professor of social psychology at the University of Florida.
确实有，尽管连无聊研究专家自己似乎也对它是一个研究领域感到惊讶。我想，没有哪个小孩子在成长过程中会说：“你知道我长大后真正想做的是什么吗？我想研究无聊。”所以这当然是完全没有计划的。这是艾琳·韦斯特盖特。她是佛罗里达大学社会心理学的助理教授。
And one of her specialties is boredom. And Erin says one good reason to study boredom is that for starters, most people don't have the first clue about how boredom works, including apparently their own. One of the fun things about being a boredom researcher is like when I meet someone,
她的专长之一是无聊。艾琳说，研究无聊的一个好理由是，首先，大多数人对无聊是如何运作的毫无头绪，显然包括他们自己。作为一名无聊研究人员，有趣的事情之一是当我遇到某人时，
the conversation usually goes like this. Hi, I'm Erin. I know what do you study? I study boredom and they go, oh, I never get bored. And that always takes me back. I'm like, because I want to be like, yes, you do. It's so funny is I was thinking the exact same thing. I never get bored. Oh, you never get bored?
对话通常是这样的。嗨，我是艾琳。我知道，你研究什么？我研究无聊。他们会说，哦，我从来不会感到无聊。这总是让我感到惊讶。我想说，是的，你会的。太有趣了，因为我当时也在想同样的事情。我从来不会感到无聊。哦，你从来不会感到无聊？
Oh, yeah. That's what it is. Well, you see, this is where Erin would prove you wrong, because this is her specialty. She gets this kind of evil genius thrill out of bringing unsuspecting people into the lab and figuring out ways to bore them to death. People hate my studies. They're so bad.
哦，是的。就是这样。好吧，你看，这就是艾琳会证明你错的地方，因为这是她的专长。她有一种邪恶天才般的快感，把毫无戒心的人带进实验室，想方设法让他们无聊至死。人们讨厌我的研究。它们太糟糕了。
Like, it's like they come up with these deep briefings at the end. We say, how was it? And they just look at me and they're like, that was the most boring thing I've ever done. And inside I'm like, yes, yes, I'm so glad. So what is the most boring thing she has them do? I'm paradoxically, I'm pretty interested in how boring she can make someone's life. Yeah, and that's the thing is I think, you know,
就像，他们在最后进行简报时。我们问，感觉怎么样？他们只是看着我，说，那是我做过的最无聊的事情。而我在心里想，是的，是的，我太高兴了。那么她让他们做的最无聊的事情是什么？矛盾的是，我对她能让一个人的生活变得多无聊很感兴趣。是的，这就是重点，我认为，你知道，
you say you don't get bored, but the truth is, like you have been presented like with boring tasks in life that you have have no choice but to concentrate on. So maybe just a video of a sidewalk, literally one foot above the sidewalk, point it down. And because you don't know it's a boredom study, you expect something to happen, but nothing happens. Or it will be something like, you're going to play this air traffic control game where
你说你不会感到无聊，但事实是，你生活中也遇到过无聊的任务，你别无选择，只能集中注意力。所以也许只是一个人行道的视频，离人行道只有一英尺高，向下指着。因为你不知道这是一个无聊研究，你期待发生点什么，但什么也没发生。或者它会是这样的：你要玩这个空中交通管制游戏，
you get to direct all this trafficking, you have to make sure all the planes land safely and this is out works and people are like, oh, okay, again, but then they make it really easy, they make it like stultifiably easy. And in fact, Aaron is so good at inducing boredom that her whole career started when she accidentally born some people while studying something slightly different. So what was that study and how did it lead her to focus on boredom? So a little more than five years ago, Aaron was running this study where they were trying to find out how much people enjoy being left alone with their own thoughts. And so what they did is they gathered a bunch of participants in a lab and first exposed them to a quick electric shock.
你可以指挥所有的交通，你必须确保所有的飞机安全着陆，这就是它的工作方式，人们会说，哦，好的，再次，但随后他们让它变得非常容易，他们让它变得极其无聊。事实上，艾琳在诱导无聊方面非常擅长，她的整个职业生涯始于她在研究其他稍微不同的东西时意外地让一些人感到无聊。那么那是什么研究，它是如何引导她专注于无聊的呢？所以五年多前，艾琳正在进行这项研究，他们试图找出人们在独自思考时有多享受。所以他们做的是，召集了一群参与者在实验室里，首先让他们接触了一次快速的电击。
It's a nasty little electricity put around your ankle, so I always say it kind of participants in a lab and first exposed them to a quick electric shock. It's a nasty little electronic put around your ankle, so I always say it kind of feels like a cat like biting your ankle, you know, like if a cat dives out and attacks you. And not surprisingly, most participants said they did not like being shocked, but then she says they told the same participants
这是一种绕在脚踝上的讨厌的小电流，所以我总是说它有点像猫咬你的脚踝，你知道，就像如果一只猫突然跳出来攻击你。不出所料，大多数参与者说他们不喜欢被电击，但她说他们告诉同样的参与者
to just sit in this room, no magazines, no phone, and just enjoy being along with their thoughts for a little while. Oh, and by the way, that little button that electricarder still hooked up if you want, I don't know what you'd want to, but if you want, you can press the button and it will still deliver an electric shock. And then we simply left them in the room by themselves for, it was actually 15 minutes and waited to see what they would do. And apparently one quarter of the women, and I'm sad to report two thirds of the men, chose to shock themselves and most people shock themselves multiple times.
只是坐在房间里，没有杂志，没有手机，只是享受一会儿独自思考的时光。哦，顺便说一句，那个电击按钮如果你们想要的话仍然连着，我不知道你们为什么会想要，但如果你们想要，你们可以按下按钮，它仍然会产生电击。然后我们只是把他们单独留在房间里，实际上是15分钟，等着看他们会做什么。显然，四分之一的女性，我很遗憾地报告，三分之二的男性，选择了电击自己，而且大多数人多次电击自己。
Oh, that is incredible. There was one man, it was a man who shocked himself. Oh, I forget, and I was well over a hundred times. Can I just say, though, that that guy then, that guy, he was definitely not bored. Oh no, he was having the time of his life. He was like, this like exactly what I always needed. But apparently a lot of the participants who shopped themselves were not like that guy. When asked why they did it they were just like like a board and it was better than nothing.
哦，那太不可思议了。有一个人，是一个电击自己的人。哦，我忘了，他电击了远不止一百次。我可以插一句吗，那个人，那个人，他绝对不无聊。哦不，他正过着他一生中最快乐的时光。他就像，这正是他一直需要的。但显然很多电击自己的参与者并不像那个人。当被问及为什么这样做时，他们只是说，很无聊，这比什么都不做要好。
It's like you're in a waiting room and there's a 10 year old magazine and like you're actually reading it for the first, you know like you never never read it otherwise, but in a really boring setting, you just go for it. Right. And then you can like, you can devolve from there, you're like done with the magazine now. You have like the candy wrapper, nutritional information. And then below that is the electrode strapped to your ankle that feels like a cat fighting you.
就像你在候诊室里，有一本10年前的杂志，你实际上是第一次读它，你知道，你平时绝不会读它，但在一个非常无聊的环境中，你就会去读。没错。然后你可以从那里开始堕落，你就像，现在杂志读完了。你有糖果包装纸上的营养信息。而在那下面是绑在你脚踝上的电极，感觉就像一只猫在抓你。
Like a might as well. Yeah. You know, which I find kind of sad, but Aaron, evil, genius, that she is, she just thought like fascinating. It was this magnificent, wonderful puzzle, and I got totally hooked, and I sort of switched gears and hardly started investigating what boredom is, why we experience it, and what happens when we do. So let's just start with that first question. That's what is boredom. One of the things that makes this hard for me to sort of picture what boredom studies are about is what is the scientific basis of boredom?
就像，不妨试试。你知道，我觉得这有点可悲，但艾琳，那个邪恶的天才，她只是觉得这太迷人了。这是一个宏伟、美妙的谜题，我完全被迷住了，我改变了方向，开始研究什么是无聊，为什么我们经历它，以及当我们经历它时会发生什么。所以让我们从第一个问题开始。让我很难想象无聊研究是什么的原因之一是，无聊的科学基础是什么？
Is there actually a distinct emotion that you can pin down and measure? Or is it just a word that actually means a variety of things? Well, this is actually where things get really interesting because that is something we're still trying to figure out in some ways. Aaron says that in the last two decades, there has been a growing consensus that boredom is in fact a real emotion.
真的有一种你可以确定并测量的独特情绪吗？还是它只是一个实际上意味着多种事物的词？好吧，这实际上是事情变得非常有趣的地方，因为这是我们仍在试图以某种方式弄清楚的事情。艾琳说，在过去的二十年里，人们越来越一致地认为无聊实际上是一种真实的情绪。
And just like other emotions, it's not intrinsically good or bad. Much like pain, it's a signal telling you something is a miss with your situation bad, much like pain, it's a signal telling you something is a miss with your situation that needs to be changed somehow. But when it comes to the question of what exactly is a miss, in other words, when it comes to Aaron's second question, why do we get bored?
就像其他情绪一样，它本质上并不好也不坏。就像疼痛一样，它是一个信号，告诉你你的处境出了问题，需要以某种方式改变。但当谈到到底出了什么问题的问题时，换句话说，当谈到艾琳的第二个问题，为什么我们会感到无聊时？
That's where the scientific consensus ends. When you get down to the nitty gritty of what exactly is causing boredom, you're gonna start finding a lot of disagreements. So there are folks, for instance, who prefer to define boredom, is just about attention. This is the attentional model, the idea of being that you get bored when you're stuck doing something that requires only a little attention. So the rest of your attentional capacities,
这就是科学共识结束的地方。当你深入探讨到底是什么导致了无聊时，你会开始发现很多分歧。例如，有些人更喜欢将无聊定义为仅仅关于注意力。这就是注意力模型，其观点是你被困在只需要一点点注意力的事情上时就会感到无聊。所以你剩余的注意力容量，
desperately looking for something else to do, in which case you just kind of check out and the task loses all meaning. There's other folks that are like no, no, no, no, no, you have it completely backwards. It's all about meaning. If you have trouble paying attention to something in your board, it's because that thing wasn't meaningful. And this is the meaning-based model. And the meaning-based model for an experience to not be boring, it just needs to seem somehow worthwhile. So you could do a challenging puzzle that requires the right amount of attention, but if you don't find it genuinely interesting, it's still boring.
拼命寻找其他事情做，在这种情况下，你只是有点心不在焉，任务就失去了所有的意义。还有其他人会说，不，不，不，不，不，你完全搞反了。这完全是关于意义。如果你在做某事时难以集中注意力，那是因为那件事没有意义。这就是基于意义的模型。而基于意义的模型认为，要让一种体验不无聊，它只需要看起来有价值。所以你可以做一个需要适度注意力的挑战性拼图，但如果你觉得它并不真正有趣，它仍然是无聊的。
Or conversely, you can do something repetitive and simple, but if you think it's saving lives, you work at bored. That's really interesting. I mean, I think I kind of see how both models work. I mean, it makes me wonder if they're entirely separate emotions or, I don't know, it just seems like it's really hard to tell how you would know which one is true. Yeah, exactly. And Aaron works with a model that tries to incorporate both, but this is where your original question is Bordam just a word actually comes back into into play. So for instance, in French, the word for boredom really alludes more to it's like what we would think of as its meaning components. In German, the word for boredom emphasizes the sense that time is slowing down.
或者相反，你可以做一些重复且简单的事情，但如果你认为它在拯救生命，你就不会感到无聊。这真的很有趣。我的意思是，我想我有点明白这两种模型是如何运作的。我的意思是，这让我怀疑它们是否是完全独立的两种情绪，或者，我不知道，似乎很难判断哪一个是真的。是的，完全正确。Aaron 使用的模型试图将两者结合起来，但这就是你最初的问题——“无聊”这个词本身——再次发挥作用的地方。例如，在法语中，无聊这个词确实更多地暗示了我们所认为的意义成分。在德语中，无聊这个词强调时间变慢的感觉。
Which is a classic symptom of attentional boredom. And in Japanese, there are in fact two different words for boredom that loosely map on to fact two different words for boredom that loosely map on to these two different meanings. And so, you know, is this one of those cases where the sort of the word actually affects the meaning, they become sort of self-fulfilling prophecies, where if you're French, you only get bored in a meaningful way. And if you're German, you get bored in these sort of attentional way. We don't know yet. And Aaron points out that even within English, there's this issue that the word boredom didn't even really exist before 1600.
这是注意力无聊的典型症状。事实上，在日语中，有两个不同的词来表达无聊，大致对应于这两个不同的含义。所以，你知道，这是否属于那种词汇实际上影响了意义的情况？它们是否变成了某种自我实现的预言，如果你是法国人，你只会以一种有意义的方式感到无聊。而如果你是德国人，你只会以这种注意力的方式感到无聊。我们还不知道。Aaron 指出，即使在英语中，也存在一个问题，即“无聊”（boredom）这个词在 1600 年之前甚至根本不存在。
And it's not clear to me how much boredom is something that is a problem of modernity. I think there's very, very limited data right now that speaks to this point at all. So it strikes me that figuring this out isn't just an intellectual exercise because, you know, our understanding of boredom must have some kind of public health implications, especially when you imagine, you know, like how we respond to being bored, like as a culture, like, do we have a problem with boredom to make people you know do bad things that's a good question because we know there is a correlation at least between people reporting being bored and things like depression anxiety substance abuse self-harm
我不清楚无聊在多大程度上是一个现代性问题。我认为目前关于这一点的数据非常非常有限。所以我觉得弄清楚这一点不仅仅是一个智力练习，因为，你知道，我们对无聊的理解必须具有某种公共卫生意义，特别是当你想象，你知道，我们作为一个文化如何应对无聊时，比如，我们是否有无聊的问题，导致人们做坏事？这是一个好问题，因为我们知道，人们报告的无聊感与抑郁、焦虑、药物滥用、自残等之间至少存在相关性。
but also pursuit of education and social connections and exercise. So this is one reason why Aaron's third and final big question is, what do we do once we're bored? And it turns out it's also the question which COVID-19 and the quarantine might actually help us answer. Yeah, I can see where this is heading. And there's a lot of people who are bored at home right now,
但也与对教育、社会联系和锻炼的追求有关。所以这就是 Aaron 的第三个也是最后一个大问题的原因：当我们感到无聊时，我们该怎么办？事实证明，这也是 COVID-19 和隔离可能实际上能帮助我们回答的问题。是的，我能看出这正朝着什么方向发展。现在有很多在家里感到无聊的人，
but lay it out for me. What is she gonna look look at. Okay so there's this big mystery right? How is boredom affecting us including one we're bored, do most of us start doing something healthy or something unhealthy and unfortunately for Aaron and other boredom researchers, the data on this is just all over the place. For instance, there's some work that finds that experimentally inducing boredom increases pro-social behavior. There's other work that finds that experimentally inducing boredom increases anti-social behavior. So which is it?
但请为我详细说明一下。她打算研究什么？好吧，这是一个巨大的谜团，对吧？无聊是如何影响我们的，包括当我们无聊时，我们大多数人是开始做一些健康的事情还是不健康的事情？不幸的是，对于 Aaron 和其他无聊研究人员来说，这方面的数据非常混乱。例如，有一些研究发现，实验性地诱导无聊会增加亲社会行为。也有其他研究发现，实验性地诱导无聊会增加反社会行为。那么到底是哪一个呢？
And Aaron says that the thing getting the way of good data and a clear answer on this is which activities people turn to when bored can be really hard to study in a lab setting. For the simple reason that when you can find people to a lab, you can't actually give them that many options of things to do. So you're in the boring group, you're not, you can shock yourself or not.
Aaron 说，阻碍获得良好数据和明确答案的原因是，人们在无聊时转向的活动在实验室环境中很难研究。原因很简单，当你把人关在实验室里时，你实际上无法给他们提供太多的选择。所以你在无聊组，你不在，你可以选择电击自己或者不电击。
You're in the boring group, you're not, you can eat a snack or not. And I don't know how useful that's going to be to us in understanding the effects of boredom in the real world, where we often have many multiple options available to us. And that question always hangs over you. Like, does this, does it matter? Who cares if you find an effect in the lab
你在无聊组，你不在，你可以吃零食或者不吃。我不知道这对我们理解现实世界中无聊的影响有多大用处，在现实世界中，我们通常有多种选择。而且那个问题总是悬在心头。就像，这重要吗？如果你在实验室里发现了某种效应，谁会在乎呢？
if no one actually does it in the real world? So obviously, there's this incentive to do studies outside of the lab in the real world, but there's a problem with reality and it's the opposite of the problem with the lab, which is people don't get bored enough. You know, for better or worse, people are not that bored all the time in everyday life. I think the bestest of it suggests people are bored around 5% all the time in everyday life. I think the bestest of it suggests people are bored around 5% of the time, which isn't really that bad.
如果现实世界中没有人真的这样做？所以很明显，人们有动力在实验室之外的现实世界中进行研究，但现实存在一个问题，它与实验室的问题相反，那就是人们不够无聊。你知道，不管好坏，人们在日常生活中并不是一直那么无聊。我认为最好的估计表明，人们在日常生活中大约 5% 的时间感到无聊，这其实并不算太糟。
If you calculate it out, it's about 30 minutes a day, but 30 minutes a day of boredom is probably not all in one chunk, it's separated out across time. And this is because most people don't stay bored for very long thanks to the structure of their daily life. They go back to work or school, almost always very quickly something happens without them even having to think about it and they stop being bored. Right. So the upshot is that you can either get people really bored in a lab,
如果你计算一下，大约是每天 30 分钟，但每天 30 分钟的无聊可能不是一次性发生的，而是分散在时间里的。这是因为大多数人由于日常生活的结构，不会长时间保持无聊。他们回到工作或学校，几乎总是很快就会发生一些事情，甚至不需要他们思考，他们就不再感到无聊了。对。所以结论是，你要么让人们在实验室里感到非常无聊，
but not see how they'd actually realistically behave. Or you could study how people realistically behave to board them, but out in the real world, they're actually rarely bored for very long, so it's hard to catch them in the act, so to speak. Exactly. And this is where the coronavirus outbreak comes in, because thanks to the quarantine, people outside the lab in the real world are, at long last, more bored, more often than they've ever been before. And for better or worse, certainly for worse for the people experiencing it, but better for me and my graduate student and my other fellow
但看不到他们实际上会如何表现。或者你可以研究人们在现实中如何应对无聊，但在现实世界中，他们实际上很少长时间感到无聊，所以很难捕捉到他们的行为。完全正确。这就是冠状病毒爆发的用武之地，因为多亏了隔离，实验室外的现实世界中的人们终于比以往任何时候都更频繁地感到无聊了。不管好坏，对经历它的人来说肯定是坏事，但对我、我的研究生以及我在世界各地的其他无聊研究人员同事来说是好事。
board and researchers around the world. Yeah, go ahead, be happy about it. Go for it. Yeah, we're kind of thrilled. I have not been bored. Other people's boredom has made very sure that I have not been bored. Other people's boredom has made very sure that I have not been bored these past few weeks. She's hours and hours of glorious boredom to study.
是的，继续，高兴吧。去做吧。是的，我们有点兴奋。我没有感到无聊。其他人的无聊确保了我过去几周没有感到无聊。其他人的无聊确保了我过去几周没有感到无聊。她有几个小时又几个小时的辉煌无聊时光可以研究。
No, yeah, it's beautiful. And so one of Aaron's doctoral students named E. Jean Linn proposed doing this study. And to be clear, this does not actually fit the formal definition of a natural experiment. Right. So it's the boredom level isn't the only variable that's changed, like some of the out-of-house activities that people might turn to when their board are like off the table. Yeah, but on the plus side, it is potentially getting people bored in this kind of sustained way, where they have to make up their own minds about what to do if they hope to be unborn. And so Aaron's team is really curious to see what activities people choose. And one way they're doing that is they're having participants fill out this kind of daily survey of how they've been feeling and what they've been up to, in which they can choose
不，是的，这很美。所以 Aaron 的一名博士生 E. Jean Linn 提议进行这项研究。需要明确的是，这实际上并不符合自然实验的正式定义。对。所以无聊程度并不是唯一改变的变量，比如人们在无聊时可能会转向的一些户外活动现在都无法进行了。是的，但从积极的一面来看，它确实有可能让人们以这种持续的方式感到无聊，他们必须自己决定如果想摆脱无聊该做什么。所以 Aaron 的团队非常好奇人们会选择什么活动。他们正在做的一件事是让参与者填写这种关于他们的感受和他们一直在做什么的日常调查，他们可以选择
from this checklist of possible activities. And other researchers keep asking, oh, can you add this to the checklist? Can you add that to the checklist? Because there's so many questions, are people baking sourdough bread out of boredom? Are people buying games out of boredom? Are people, there's a whole set of question, are people hooking up and becoming lovers
从这个可能的活动清单中进行选择。其他研究人员一直在问，哦，你能把这个加到清单里吗？你能把那个加到清单里吗？因为有太多的问题，人们是因为无聊而烤酸面包吗？人们是因为无聊而购买游戏吗？人们，有一整套问题，人们是因为无聊而和室友
with their roommates out of boredom? What's going on? What are people doing? And so they becoming lovers with their roommates out of boredom. Like what's going on? What are people doing? And so, you know, they're looking into all sorts of things. They're looking into whether there is a discrepancy between how people think they react to boredom versus how they actually react to boredom. And also, you know, is boredom followed
成为恋人吗？发生了什么？人们在做什么？所以，你知道，他们正在研究各种各样的事情。他们正在研究人们认为自己对无聊的反应与他们实际对无聊的反应之间是否存在差异。而且，你知道，无聊之后是否会
by maladaptive behaviors, including breaking the quarantine. But also, they can record something that by definition is almost impossible to record in the lab, which is novelty seeking. People trying things they've never tried before. And so just recently, I asked her to send me a list of some of these novel activities that people are trying. And it's just, in some ways, it's just very sweet. So spray painted a string of lights outside, tried a new hair color, tried making my own music, went
出现适应不良的行为，包括打破隔离。但他们也可以记录一些在实验室里几乎不可能记录的东西，那就是寻求新奇感。人们尝试他们从未尝试过的事情。所以就在最近，我让她给我发了一份人们正在尝试的一些新奇活动的清单。在某些方面，这真的很可爱。所以，在外面喷漆了一串灯，尝试了一种新的发色，尝试制作自己的音乐，去
under my house to look for a dead rat, used my cats to help search for the rat. But also watch the church sermon with my family, something we don't do very often, helped my little brother set up a kite to find the front yard, talk to a new person, and then a few fun ones. I'm about to smoke weed. It's slim gyms for breakfast. That's pretty grim. Yeah, some of these are, you could classifies maladaptive behavior. That's so far. And actually, I think we can joke about this, like, oh, we're baking bread, oh, we're doing this little thing. And they might seem even like kind of banal to us.
我的房子下面找一只死老鼠，用我的猫帮忙寻找老鼠。但也和家人一起看了教堂布道，这是我们不常做的事情，帮我弟弟在院子里搭了一个风筝，和一个新的人交谈，还有一些有趣的。我正要抽大麻。早餐吃 Slim Jims。这太阴暗了。是的，其中一些，你可以归类为适应不良的行为。到目前为止。实际上，我认为我们可以拿这个开玩笑，比如，哦，我们在烤面包，哦，我们在做这个小事。它们对我们来说甚至可能看起来有点平庸。
But to Erin and her fellow researchers, these are like these precious stones. And precisely, these are the activities that they weren't able to study or record and lab. And now they're getting them. So we might not have the experimental control out in the world, but we have something that's just as valuable, which is reality. So they have all the boredom of the lab,
但对 Erin 和她的研究同事来说，这些就像珍贵的宝石。准确地说，这些是他们在实验室里无法研究或记录的活动。现在他们得到了。所以我们可能在现实世界中没有实验控制，但我们拥有同样有价值的东西，那就是现实。所以他们拥有实验室里所有的无聊，
but all the novelty possibilities of the real world, that's a really kind of amazing experiment to have land at your feet. Yeah, and for Aaron, it really gets back to these core questions. What is boredom? And what should we do with it? I think the thing I always try to touch on is that boredom's not good or bad, except that we make it so that boredom is an important signal. It's healthy, it's adaptive. We would not get very far without it.
但拥有现实世界中所有的可能性，这是一个非常令人惊叹的实验，落在了你的脚边。是的，对于 Aaron 来说，它确实回到了这些核心问题。什么是无聊？我们应该拿它怎么办？我想我总是试图触及的一点是，无聊本身没有好坏之分，除非我们让它变得如此，无聊是一个重要的信号。它是健康的，是适应性的。没有它，我们走不了多远。
Boredom makes sure that we stay engaged in the world and it doesn't feel good, but that's okay. It just depends on how we react to it. Yeah, but in that way Bordam is like all things. Yeah, it's like everything else, but with its own unique mysteries, which in this weird, unexpected, accidental way, we just might get to learn a little bit more about. Well, it's super interesting. Well, thanks so much, Joe.
无聊确保我们保持与世界的接触，虽然感觉不好，但这没关系。这只取决于我们如何应对它。是的，从这个意义上说，无聊就像所有事物一样。是的，它就像其他一切一样，但有其独特的谜团，以这种奇怪的、意想不到的、偶然的方式，我们可能刚好能多了解一点。嗯，这超级有趣。嗯，非常感谢你，Joe。
Thank you so much to Professor Aaron Westgate and her doctoral student, Yee-Jane Lynn, at the University of Florida for helping us investigate the great mystery that is boredom. To learn more about their research, you can visit Aaron's website at AaronWestgate.com, where you can also volunteer to participate in one of her ongoing COVID-19 studies. Whether you're bored or not, Erin wants to know. Now I'm talking with Delaney Hall or senior editor and who is currently trapped in her home in Santa Fe with two children, two small children. Yes, yes, I hope you cannot hear them screaming in the background. I actually sent everyone outside because working from your home, there's no sound isolation.
非常感谢佛罗里达大学的 Aaron Westgate 教授和她的博士生 Yee-Jane Lynn 帮助我们调查无聊这个伟大的谜团。要了解更多关于他们的研究，你可以访问 Aaron 的网站 AaronWestgate.com，在那里你也可以自愿参加她正在进行的 COVID-19 研究之一。无论你是否感到无聊，Erin 都想知道。现在我和 Delaney Hall 交谈，她是我们的高级编辑，目前正和两个孩子，两个小孩一起被困在圣达菲的家中。是的，是的，我希望你听不到他们在背景中尖叫。我实际上把每个人都赶到了外面，因为在家工作，没有隔音效果。
No, totally. There's no amount of foam padding that will protect you from little children. It's just the way it is. Yeah. So, how are you coping there with the children? Well, I've actually been spending a lot of time in a couple of different parenting-related Facebook groups where parents are commiserating with each other and sharing tips about how to get through this crazy time.
不，完全没有。没有任何泡沫垫能保护你免受小孩的干扰。事实就是这样。是的。那么，你和孩子们在那里相处得怎么样？嗯，我实际上花了很多时间在几个不同的育儿相关的 Facebook 群组中，家长们在那里互相倾诉，分享如何度过这段疯狂时光的建议。
And I recently came across a post in one of those groups that got me thinking about this idea of the natural experiment. recently came across a post in one of those groups that got me thinking about this idea of the natural experiment. The post was about vaccination, which honestly is a subject that does not come up that often in this group. Yeah, I mean, that's always a hot button topic, and even if you have strong scientific based feeling about the subject, you just don't want to fight with strangers on the internet about it.
我最近在其中一个群组中看到了一篇帖子，让我开始思考自然实验这个想法。最近在其中一个群组中看到了一篇帖子，让我开始思考自然实验这个想法。这篇帖子是关于疫苗接种的，老实说，这是一个在这个群组中不常出现的话题。是的，我的意思是，那总是一个热门话题，即使你对这个主题有强烈的科学依据的感受，你也不想在互联网上与陌生人争论。
Yeah, exactly. But this post just went there, head on. And to paraphrase, it basically said, we're all terrified of this disease that's going around. And we're living in lockdown. And this is what life looks like without vaccines. This is how life used to be. And the post really struck me like I've been thinking a lot about it.
是的，完全正确。但这篇帖子直接切入主题。意译一下，它基本上说，我们都对这种正在传播的疾病感到恐惧。我们生活在封锁中。这就是没有疫苗的生活。这就是过去的生活。这篇帖子真的触动了我，我一直在思考它。
And what would aspect have you been thinking about? Well, the sentiment of the post represents my feelings. Like I cannot wait for a vaccine. But it also made me wonder about people who are anti-vaccination. Like how are they experiencing this moment as the pandemic unfolds? Are people's minds changing? And so I started looking around for a researcher who studies those issues and who would have some insight into how a pandemic might influence people's attitudes about vaccines.
你一直在思考哪一方面？嗯，这篇帖子的情绪代表了我的感受。就像我迫不及待地想要疫苗一样。但它也让我对反疫苗接种的人感到好奇。他们在这个大流行展开的时刻是如何体验的？人们的想法在改变吗？所以我开始寻找一位研究这些问题的研究人员，他会对大流行如何影响人们对疫苗的态度有一些见解。
You know, this is a generation defining experience. My dad's 95. He doesn't remember anything ever like this in his lifetime. This is Dr. Bernice Hausman, and she leads the Department of Humanities within the Penn State College of Medicine. So it's almost like two big an experience when you're in it to figure out how you're going to study it. So what Dr. Houseman studies is the history and meaning of anti-vaccination sentiment. She looks at what vaccine deceners actually believe and why. And more broadly, she's interested in medical controversies
你知道，这是一次定义一代人的经历。我爸爸 95 岁了。他一生中从未记得有这样的事情。这是 Bernice Hausman 博士，她领导宾夕法尼亚州立大学医学院的人文系。所以当你身处其中时，这几乎是一次太大的经历，以至于无法弄清楚你将如何研究它。所以 Hausman 博士研究的是反疫苗接种情绪的历史和意义。她研究疫苗反对者实际上相信什么以及为什么。更广泛地说，她对医学争议感兴趣，
that spill over into the public realm and become social controversies. This interface between science and society, right? You have to work with people, which means you're working with culture and tradition and ritual and history, not just with science. And if it were just science, then there wouldn't be a controversy, right? I mean, this is a situation where the scientific evidence shows that vaccines are really important,
这些争议蔓延到公共领域并成为社会争议。科学与社会之间的这种接口，对吧？你必须与人合作，这意味着你正在与文化、传统、仪式和历史合作，而不仅仅是与科学合作。如果这只是科学，那么就不会有争议，对吧？我的意思是，这是一种科学证据表明疫苗非常重要的情况，
like essential for public health, but that hasn't changed the fact that there are people skeptical about them. Right, and if you understand the history of where that skepticism comes from and why it's so durable and how it connects to these very big ideas about individual freedom and state power, all of that helps you understand why the phenomenon continues today, even in the middle of a global pandemic. So, Roman, do you wanna hear some really disgusting, early vaccination history? Absolutely. I thought you would.
就像对公共卫生至关重要一样，但这并没有改变人们对它们持怀疑态度的事实。对，如果你了解这种怀疑来自何处的历史，为什么它如此持久，以及它如何与这些关于个人自由和国家权力的宏大思想联系起来，所有这些都有助于你理解为什么这种现象今天仍在继续，即使在全球大流行期间。所以，Roman，你想听一些非常令人作呕的早期疫苗接种历史吗？当然。我就知道你会想听。
Okay, so the earliest method of immunization, which dates back to the 10th century, was something called variolation, and it was used to protect people against smallpox. And the way it worked is that you would scrape a little pus out of a smallpox blister, and then scratch your arm and put the pus into the wound. Oh my god.
好吧，最早的免疫方法可以追溯到 10 世纪，被称为“人痘接种法”（variolation），它被用来保护人们免受天花的侵害。它的工作原理是，你从天花水泡中刮出一点脓液，然后抓破你的手臂，把脓液放进伤口里。天哪。
Yeah, or, or, alternately, you could also take a scab from the smallpox blister and then crush it up and suck it up your own nose. With either method, the idea was that hopefully a mild and protective infection would result. The idea that if they had a mild course of the disease, they would not be scarred and they would survive. It had a pretty significant mortality rate, but not as high as smallpox itself. And so after a while, variolation spread from China and India where it originated into the
是的，或者，或者，你可以从天花水泡中取一个痂，然后把它压碎，吸进你自己的鼻子里。无论哪种方法，想法都是希望产生一种轻微且具有保护性的感染。想法是，如果他们患有轻微的疾病，他们就不会留下疤痕，并且他们会存活下来。它的死亡率相当高，但没有天花本身那么高。所以过了一段时间，人痘接种法从起源地中国和印度传播到了
West. And eventually the practice gave way to vaccination. In the late 1700s, an English physician named Edward Jenner made a vaccine for smallpox that was based on cowpox, a related animal infection. And amazingly, that's actually where the word vaccination comes from. It's based on the Latin word Vaca for cow. Okay, so a lot of people welcomed the many new vaccines that began to develop from that point forward, but there were also objections right from the start. Some of them based on the notion that you should not mess around with nature.
西方。最终，这种做法被疫苗接种所取代。在 18 世纪末，一位名叫 Edward Jenner 的英国医生制造了一种基于牛痘（一种相关的动物感染）的天花疫苗。令人惊讶的是，这实际上就是“疫苗接种”（vaccination）这个词的由来。它基于拉丁语单词 Vaca，意思是牛。好吧，所以很多人欢迎从那时起开始发展的许多新疫苗，但从一开始也有反对意见。其中一些基于你不应该干扰自然的观念。
It's always dangerous to mess around with nature. People who do so are punished. There were anti-scientific arguments based on the notion of naturally becoming ill as was preferable to being vaccinated. There were perceptions of the dangers of vaccination. So all of the same concerns that we see today in contemporary vaccination descent, you can see them historically. And a big sticking point for a lot of people were vaccine mandates. People hated the idea of the state requiring them to vaccinate, which started happening pretty quickly.
干扰自然总是危险的。这样做的人会受到惩罚。有一些反科学的论点基于自然患病比接种疫苗更可取的观念。人们对疫苗接种的危险性有看法。所以我们在当代疫苗接种反对中看到的所有担忧，你都可以在历史上看到。对很多人来说，一个巨大的症结是疫苗强制令。人们讨厌国家要求他们接种疫苗的想法，这种情况很快就开始发生了。
Great Britain implemented compulsory vaccination in the mid-1800s, and people actually rioted. Well, I mean, I don't know. I mean, I think people, when it comes to civil liberties, they're really thinking about their bodies. You know, it's the ultimate divide in line, you know, that that's only theirs. But you can see why they would be required,
英国在 19 世纪中期实施了强制疫苗接种，人们实际上发生了暴乱。嗯，我的意思是，我不知道。我的意思是，我认为人们在谈到公民自由时，他们实际上是在考虑他们的身体。你知道，这是最终的界限，你知道，那是只属于他们的。但你可以看出为什么它们会被要求，
because, you know, you mandate a vaccine, because it only works if a critical mass of people do it. Like, you have to get that herd immunity going. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And so it kind of presents this catch 22. If you didn't have the mandate, you probably wouldn't have the movement movement because the mandate is what forces people who don't want to vaccinate to vaccinate their children. So our mandate is the way to go. That is a really
因为，你知道，你强制接种疫苗，因为它只有在关键数量的人接种时才有效。就像，你必须实现群体免疫。是的，是的，完全正确。所以它有点像是一个“第 22 条军规”。如果你没有强制令，你可能就不会有运动，因为强制令是迫使那些不想接种疫苗的人为他们的孩子接种疫苗的原因。所以我们的强制令是正确的方法。这是一个非常
interesting question because it feels like mandates are both very American and very un-American. In the sense that, you know, we really have a tradition of individual personal liberty in this country and the notion that the state cannot make you do certain things. And so, I don't think the mandates are going away, but I do think that we see the friction that they cause at the political level. So here in the U.S., vaccine to centers organized to challenge those mandates. And then eventually in 1905, there was a famous Supreme Court case, which you actually covered on Trump Conlogue a couple of weeks ago.
有趣的问题，因为它感觉强制令既非常美国化，又非常不美国化。从某种意义上说，你知道，我们在这个国家确实有个人自由的传统，而且国家不能强迫你做某些事情的观念。所以，我不认为强制令会消失，但我确实认为我们看到了它们在政治层面上造成的摩擦。所以在美国，疫苗反对者组织起来挑战这些强制令。然后最终在 1905 年，发生了一个著名的最高法院案件，你实际上在几周前在 Trump Conlogue 上报道过。
I know this one. This is Jacobson versus Massachusetts, which upheld the rights of states to enforce vaccination laws. And it basically said that, you know, sometimes public welfare is more important than individual freedom. Right. And even though the decision did allow for some exemptions, it was one of the things that really mobilized the anti-vaccination movement in the US. It provided fuel. And as time went on, Dr. Houseman said that two broad groups of vaccine dissenters began to emerge. The one group is a sort of more ideologically anti-vaccination group, right?
我知道这个。这是 Jacobson 诉马萨诸塞州案，它维护了各州执行疫苗接种法的权利。它基本上说，你知道，有时公共福利比个人自由更重要。对。尽管该裁决确实允许一些豁免，但它是真正动员美国反疫苗接种运动的事情之一。它提供了燃料。随着时间的推移，Hausman 博士说，两类广泛的疫苗反对者开始出现。第一类是一个更具意识形态的反疫苗接种群体，对吧？
So this is the group that is against the science of vaccination. They may use their own scientific evidence. They're largely middle-class educated people who believe that vaccination is dangerous or wrong in some way. And then there's another group of people, often working class people who object to the government's intrusion on the family. So these are people who believe the government just should not be telling people what to do with their bodies, kind of like you were talking about earlier, that that is the realm of the individual,
所以这是反对疫苗接种科学的群体。他们可能会使用自己的科学证据。他们主要是受过教育的中产阶级，认为疫苗接种在某种程度上是危险的或错误的。然后还有另一群人，通常是工人阶级，他们反对政府对家庭的侵入。所以这些人认为政府根本不应该告诉人们如何处理他们的身体，有点像你刚才谈到的，那是属于个人的领域，
that is the realm of the family. And it's worth pointing out that sometimes this was for a good reason. You know, working class people in general had a harder time getting out of vaccination. People with more money could just pay a fine and skip it. So working class people were often forced to do this thing that they objected to. What you tend to see in the United States at least is a mingling of arguments about freedom
那是属于家庭的领域。值得指出的是，有时这是有充分理由的。你知道，工人阶级的人通常更难逃避疫苗接种。有更多钱的人可以支付罚款并跳过它。所以工人阶级的人经常被迫做他们反对的事情。你倾向于看到的，至少在美国，是关于自由的论点
and about individual rights with the notion of bodily danger. And this idea of bodily danger is really compelling to people. Dr. Hausmann made this point that was really interesting. She said that public support for vaccination is actually very fragile, meaning that even if the benefits of vaccination far outweigh the risks, all it takes for some people to abandon it is just a small number of bad outcomes. And so what are some examples of that? So something that you can see historically is the power of media that highlights a few
和关于个人权利的论点与身体危险观念的混合。这种身体危险的观念对人们来说非常有吸引力。Hausman 博士提出了一个非常有趣的观点。她说，公众对疫苗接种的支持实际上非常脆弱，这意味着即使疫苗接种的好处远大于风险，对某些人来说，放弃它所需要的只是少数几个糟糕的结果。那么这方面的一些例子是什么？所以你在历史上可以看到的是媒体的力量，它突出了几个
vivid worst case scenarios. So Dr. Hausmann traces the modern anti-vaccination movement to the 1970s. And that was when parents started to express concerns about the original pertussis vaccine, which caused high fevers and febrile seizures in some children. In the 1970s, there was an increasing belief that it could cause some neurological damage.
生动的最坏情况。所以 Hausman 博士将现代反疫苗接种运动追溯到 20 世纪 70 年代。那时家长们开始对最初的百日咳疫苗表示担忧，该疫苗在一些儿童中引起了高烧和热性惊厥。在 20 世纪 70 年代，人们越来越相信它可能会导致一些神经损伤。
There was a paper that was published in Britain claiming that it actually did so. There is controversy about whether or not that paper is valid. And in the early 1980s, there was an influential TV news story called vaccine roulette that highlighted some of these concerns. It aired on a local NBC affiliate in Washington, D.C. It aired on a local NBC affiliate in Washington, D.C. It's a fact of life. All children must get four D.P.T. shots to go to school. Shots we are told will keep our children healthy.
英国发表了一篇论文，声称它确实造成了这种情况。关于那篇论文是否有效存在争议。在 20 世纪 80 年代初，有一个有影响力的电视新闻报道叫“疫苗轮盘赌”（vaccine roulette），突出了其中一些担忧。它在华盛顿特区的一家当地 NBC 附属机构播出。它在华盛顿特区的一家当地 NBC 附属机构播出。这是生活的事实。所有儿童必须接种四次 D.P.T. 疫苗才能上学。我们被告知，这些疫苗将保持我们孩子的健康。
Shots we are told will protect every child from a dread disease pertussis. It's hooping cough. But the D.P.T. shot can also damage to a devastating degree. The report caused a lot of controversy. In general, it emphasized the risks of the vaccine while minimizing the dangers of the actual disease. And some of its more serious claims have since been debunked by further research. The story gave a big platform for this group called dissatisfied parents together, which would go on to become the National Vaccine Information Center. And that's one of the biggest, quote-unquote,
我们被告知，这些疫苗将保护每个孩子免受可怕的百日咳疾病的侵害。这是百日咳。但 D.P.T. 疫苗也可能造成毁灭性的损害。该报道引起了很大争议。总的来说，它强调了疫苗的风险，同时最小化了实际疾病的危险。它的一些更严重的说法后来被后续研究揭穿了。该报道为一个名为“不满的父母在一起”（Dissatisfied Parents Together）的组织提供了一个大平台，该组织后来成为了国家疫苗信息中心。这是最大的，所谓的，
vaccine safety organizations in the country. Many people would call them anti-vaxxers. Another example I'm thinking of in terms of like a single article that had outsized influence was the Andrew Wakefield, the completely fraudulent paper that linked the MMR vaccine to autism, which had no basis in anything, but it became this starting point. Yeah, that one came out in 1998, and it's been very damaging. As you said, there's no link between MMR and autism, but that association continues, and it still motivates some vaccine refusal.
全国疫苗安全组织之一。许多人会称他们为反疫苗者。我想到的另一个关于具有巨大影响力的单篇文章的例子是 Andrew Wakefield，那篇完全欺诈的论文将 MMR 疫苗与自闭症联系起来，这没有任何依据，但它成为了一个起点。是的，那篇发表于 1998 年，而且非常具有破坏性。正如你所说，MMR 和自闭症之间没有联系，但这种关联仍在继续，并且它仍然激励着一些疫苗拒绝行为。
So those are a couple of the big moments that get us to where we are today. Okay, so now that we're in this moment where an infectious disease affects our daily lives, like the coronavirus pandemic, what is Dr. Hausman seen in these different movements? So right now, she's just observing and formulating some questions that might be interesting to investigate. And to start with, she says that this is a really interesting time to be studying vaccination descent, because what we're experiencing is really unprecedented. This is the first big worldwide pandemic of the vaccine era. We haven't had one since we've had all these vaccines.
所以这些是让我们走到今天这一步的几个重大时刻。好吧，既然我们现在处于传染病影响我们日常生活的时刻，比如冠状病毒大流行，Hausman 博士在这些不同的运动中看到了什么？所以现在，她只是在观察并提出一些可能值得调查的问题。首先，她说这是一个研究疫苗接种反对的非常有趣的时期，因为我们正在经历的事情确实是前所未有的。这是疫苗时代第一次全球性的大流行。自从我们有了所有这些疫苗以来，我们还没有经历过。
That's really the case, right? The last big pandemic like this was in 1918. So what Dr. Hausmann is doing is she's checking on these online hubs like the National Vaccine Information Center to see how they're messaging around the issue of the coronavirus. And among hardcore ideological anti-vaxxers,
确实是这样，对吧？上一次这样的大流行是在 1918 年。所以 Hausman 博士正在做的是，她正在查看这些在线中心，比如国家疫苗信息中心，看看他们是如何围绕冠状病毒问题进行信息传递的。在强硬的意识形态反疫苗者中，
there is a lot of fear. People are seeing the government enact these state home orders, requiring businesses to close. They see the heavy hand of government coming down and they are concerned about what might happen with respect to vaccines. And is this going to emboldened states to use these same powers to compel vaccine use?
有很多恐惧。人们看到政府颁布这些居家令，要求企业关闭。他们看到政府的强硬手段，他们担心疫苗方面可能会发生什么。这会鼓励各州利用同样的权力来强制使用疫苗吗？
There's a whole set of concerns around that. I feel like I've actually seen some of this manifesting in the protests against the state home orders. And they're pretty small, but they've been happening in the last couple of weeks. And if you watch the footage, you will see anti-vax signage, along with signs that talk about tyranny
围绕这一点有一整套担忧。我觉得我实际上已经看到其中一些在反对居家令的抗议活动中表现出来。它们规模很小，但在过去几周里一直在发生。如果你看录像，你会看到反疫苗标语，以及谈论暴政的标语
and needing haircuts and stuff like that. It seems to be part of that same worldview. Yeah, it's in the mix at those protests. And it's just clear that the government orders have people quite worried. I came across this video that a pastor who is also anti-vaccination posted on Twitter recently. They will be sipping frosties in the lake of fire
和需要理发之类的东西。这似乎是同一个世界观的一部分。是的，它在那些抗议活动中混杂在一起。很明显，政府的命令让人们非常担心。我最近在 Twitter 上看到了一段一位也是反疫苗接种的牧师发布的视频。他们会在火湖里啜饮冰沙
before the government ever gets their greasy grimy hands on me and my family and forces us to take a stupid implant or a vaccination that we don't believe in. I have a first amendment right that allows me to reject it and say no. I have a second amendment right that protects my first one and I have a God-given right to tell you you have gone buck wild, the government is out of control, and Christians, you need to wake up. The sort of the mingling of fear about state power and anti-vaccination seems to be
在政府把他们油腻肮脏的手伸向我和我的家人，强迫我们接受我们不相信的愚蠢植入物或疫苗接种之前。我拥有第一修正案权利，允许我拒绝它并说不。我拥有保护第一修正案的第二修正案权利，我拥有上帝赋予的权利告诉你，你已经疯了，政府失控了，基督徒们，你们需要醒醒。对国家权力的恐惧和反疫苗接种的混合似乎是
kind of a natural mix. That's happening right now. Yeah, I mean, it is not the case that the pandemic is causing really hardcore anti-vaccination people to rethink their views as I perhaps naively thought it would. In fact, it seems to be creating this environment where some people are really doubling down. Right. I mean, so I can imagine that the anti-vaxx pastor whose whole identity is wrapped up in this, not budging. But is there maybe some people on the edges that might be just a little wary of vaccines that you wouldn't present it with a world in which a vaccine would greatly improve the quality of life all around the world.
一种自然的混合。现在正在发生。是的，我的意思是，大流行并没有导致非常强硬的反疫苗接种的人重新思考他们的观点，正如我可能天真地认为的那样。事实上，它似乎正在创造一个环境，让一些人真的加倍努力。对。我的意思是，所以我可以想象那个整个身份都包裹在其中的反疫苗牧师，不会让步。但边缘上是否有一些人可能只是对疫苗有点警惕，如果你不向他们展示一个疫苗将极大地改善世界各地生活质量的世界。
I mean, are they moving at all? Dr. Hausman does think this experience will probably affect the views of people who are vaccine hesitants. So they don't have super strong beliefs about vaccine. They're not connected to these communities and movements of vaccine dissenters, but they are people who've picked up a sense of unease about vaccination. She thinks that those people, the hesitant people, might in fact come around to the idea that vaccination is a really good thing. And in fact, there's this technology that she's keeping an eye on. And this is more about the design of one of the potential coronavirus vaccines.
我的意思是，他们有任何改变吗？Hausman 博士确实认为这种经历可能会影响那些对疫苗犹豫不决的人的观点。所以他们对疫苗没有非常强烈的信念。他们没有与这些疫苗反对者的社区和运动联系在一起，但他们是那些对疫苗接种产生了一种不安感的人。她认为那些人，犹豫不决的人，实际上可能会转而认为疫苗接种是一件非常好的事情。事实上，她正在关注这项技术。这更多是关于潜在冠状病毒疫苗之一的设计。
So as you know, there are teams of researchers all around the world looking for a vaccine. And one of them is being developed at the University of Pittsburgh. And one of the interesting things about their vaccine is it's not given through a shot. It's given as a patch. It's this little patch that looks like a translucent square. So how does that work? I can't even imagine it.
所以如你所知，世界各地都有研究团队在寻找疫苗。其中一个正在匹兹堡大学开发。关于他们的疫苗，有趣的事情之一是它不是通过注射给药的。它是作为贴片给药的。这是一个看起来像半透明方块的小贴片。那么它是如何工作的呢？我甚至无法想象。
Yeah, so you place it on your skin kind of like a bandaid. And then over the course of a few days, it delivers the vaccine to your body through these tiny little needles. So there's a number of reasons why this is a really interesting technology. First of all, a lot of people don't like shots. Second of all, there are some arguments that the skin is actually a better tissue for a vaccine absorption than intramuscular injection. But then there's this other reason, which is more about the psychology of vaccines. Think about what it would mean if you went to the doctor's office and instead of giving
是的，所以你把它贴在皮肤上，就像创可贴一样。然后在几天的时间里，它通过这些微小的针头将疫苗输送到你的身体里。所以这项技术之所以非常有趣，有很多原因。首先，很多人不喜欢打针。其次，有一些论点认为皮肤实际上是比肌肉注射更好的疫苗吸收组织。但还有另一个原因，更多是关于疫苗的心理学。想想如果你去医生办公室，而不是给
your child shots, they gave you like four patches and said, okay, over the next two weeks, you do them in this sequence and then you can see if there's an adverse reaction to one of them, you're sort of more in control as a parent and even if it's the same delivery of the same vaccines, that totally changes your relationship to the entire process. Well, that is really interesting. I remember when my kids were born, there was a movement among people who were like, you know, they were in favor of vaccination, but felt maybe the MMR was too much vaccination at once. And it wouldn't be great if they gave them one at a time, for example. And so this seems to like, this ability to give you control and to sort of
你的孩子打针，他们给了你四个贴片，说，好吧，在接下来的两周里，你按这个顺序使用它们，然后你可以看看其中一个是否有不良反应，作为父母你更有控制权，即使它是相同疫苗的相同输送方式，这也完全改变了你与整个过程的关系。嗯，这真的很有趣。我记得我的孩子们出生时，在那些人中有一场运动，他们就像，你知道，他们赞成疫苗接种，但觉得 MMR 可能一次接种太多了。如果他们一次给一个，例如，那不是很好吗？所以这似乎，这种给你控制权的能力，以及某种程度上
test and watch your child, because your child is not like every other child, it's just your child, and so they have a specific reaction to everything that you can watch for. I can see that why that would psychologically help people out who were having a problem. Yeah, and as a parent, I can understand the appeal, too. And I think Dr. Hausman is hoping that this might be the vaccine that actually gets developed and licensed because she wants to study that reaction. She wants to study how the mechanism of delivery
测试和观察你的孩子，因为你的孩子不像其他任何孩子，它只是你的孩子，所以他们对你所能观察到的每件事都有特定的反应。我能看出为什么这在心理上会帮助那些有问题的父母。是的，作为父母，我也能理解这种吸引力。而且我认为 Hausman 博士希望这可能是真正被开发和许可的疫苗，因为她想研究那种反应。她想研究输送机制
might change people's attitudes about the vaccine. Right. And what's interesting is that ultimately what she's seen in this moment displays a lot of the same dynamics we've seen over and over again in history, which is that even when there's overwhelming scientific evidence that vaccines are good for public health, and we're getting a very real illustration of that right now. It doesn't necessarily mean that everyone just gets on board. And so like I guess in order to have effective public health measures, whether or not you agree or disagree, you just have to grapple with that.
可能会如何改变人们对疫苗的态度。对。有趣的是，最终她在这一刻所看到的展示了我们在历史上反复看到的许多相同的动态，那就是即使有压倒性的科学证据表明疫苗对公共卫生有益，而且我们现在正在得到一个非常真实的例证。这并不一定意味着每个人都会加入。所以我想为了采取有效的公共卫生措施，无论你是否同意，你都必须努力解决这个问题。
You have to figure out how to reach people. Yeah, she said this super interesting thing towards the end of our conversation. You know, with science-based medicine is a tremendous advantage that we have in the modern world. The fact that they could sequence the genome of the coronavirus so quickly, the fact that they're talking about a vaccine within 18 months or two years is phenomenal, right?
你必须弄清楚如何接触人们。是的，她在我们谈话结束时说了一件超级有趣的事情。你知道，以科学为基础的医学是我们现代世界拥有的巨大优势。他们能如此迅速地对冠状病毒的基因组进行测序，他们谈论在 18 个月或两年内研制出疫苗的事实是惊人的，对吧？
All of that is based on advancements in medicine. But the experience of the pandemic, the social disruption that it has caused, the difficulties of discrimination and unequal treatment that the pandemic has uncovered. We already knew it, but now we know it even more. All of that is the realm of the social world, and all of that is much more difficult in some ways to handle.
所有这些都基于医学的进步。但疫情的经历、它所造成的社会混乱、以及疫情所揭示的歧视和不平等对待的困境，我们本已了解，但现在了解得更加深刻。所有这些都属于社会世界的范畴，在某些方面，处理这些问题要困难得多。
So in other words, science is the easy part, you know, and people are hard. Coming up, experimenting with our city streets now that vehicular traffic is down and pedestrians are everywhere. After this. So our city of Oakland made its way into the national news recently for a policy initiative that I think our urbanist fans will probably appreciate that they banned cars. That's right. I mean, they banned cars on a lot of streets.
换句话说，科学是容易的部分，你知道，而人是复杂的。接下来，我们将探讨在车辆交通减少、行人随处可见的情况下，对城市街道进行的实验。稍后回来。我们的奥克兰市最近登上了全国新闻，因为一项我认为城市规划爱好者可能会赞赏的政策倡议，那就是他们禁止了汽车。没错。我的意思是，他们在许多街道上禁止了汽车。
I mean, that's, it was really remarkable. Yeah, I mean, it wasn't all cars and it wasn't all streets, but the measure came in response to crowding concerns that they were seeing at local parks and around like merit downtown. You know, we're all cooped up in our houses in the streets of the one place where we can go for a walk or a run, but with everyone doing that, it's creating problems. People were sort of encountering each other on the sidewalk
我的意思是，这真的很了不起。是的，我的意思是，并不是所有汽车都被禁，也不是所有街道都被禁，但这项措施是为了应对在当地公园和梅里特湖市中心周围看到的拥挤问题。你知道，我们都被关在家里，街道是我们唯一可以散步或跑步的地方，但当每个人都这样做时，就会产生问题。人们在人行道上相遇，
and making a decision up ahead, having this little dance, who's going to walk out into the street, who's going to cross over to the other street. This is Ryan Russo, Director of the Oakland Department of Transportation. Someone going for a run, saying, okay, they don't want me to go down to the lake where I normally run. So I'll run in the neighborhood, but I don't want to breathe heavy on people on the sidewalk. So I'm going to do that in the street too. I don't know about you, Rowan, but I've been going on a lot of runs these days wearing a mask.
不得不做出决定，像跳舞一样，谁该走到街上，谁该穿过街道。这是奥克兰交通局局长瑞安·鲁索。有人去跑步，说，好吧，他们不想让我去我通常跑步的湖边。所以我会在社区里跑，但我不想在人行道上对着别人大口喘气。所以我也会在街上跑。罗曼，我不知道你怎么样，但我这些天戴着口罩跑了很多次步。
And I've just decided that the safest way is just to go right down the middle of the road. Most sidewalks are less than six feet across. So there's just not enough room to safely share one with another pedestrian. And so the city of Oakland decided with that in mind just to close a whole bunch of streets to cars to give people more room. Right. And it's like dozens of miles of streets, right? Yeah.
我决定最安全的方法就是直接走在马路中间。大多数人行道宽度不到六英尺。所以没有足够的空间与其他行人安全地共享。考虑到这一点，奥克兰市决定关闭一大批街道，禁止汽车通行，给人们更多的空间。没错。那是几十英里的街道，对吧？是的。
So the city already has this network of what they call bike boulevards. And that's about 74 miles total. It can already be low traffic volume, but connect you to things in the neighborhoods. They actually get you places. It's not just a cold assack. And what we are doing is selecting from those 74 miles, well, which ones should get soft closure treatments? Soft closures mean that they're basically throwing up a temporary roadblock in a five-mile per hour sign. The streets are still open to people who live there, delivery trucks and emergency vehicles,
所以这个城市已经拥有他们所谓的自行车大道网络。总长约74英里。它本身交通量就可能很低，但能将你与社区里的事物连接起来。它们实际上能带你去某些地方。不仅仅是死胡同。我们正在做的是从这74英里中选择，哪些应该进行软封闭处理？软封闭意味着他们基本上是设置一个临时路障和一个限速每小时五英里的标志。街道仍然对居住在那里的人、送货卡车和紧急车辆开放，
but otherwise the street is for pedestrians and bicyclists and little kids on scooters and dads doing jump rope. I mean, what's interesting about this is that a lot of urbanists have wanted this for a long time, pandemic, or no pandemic. They just wanted to see the streets used for other purposes other than driving. Right. We've talked about this a lot on the show. I asked Ryan Russo whether this policy was part of a larger transportation vision that he had for the city.
但除此之外，街道是留给行人、骑自行车的人、骑滑板车的小孩和跳绳的爸爸们的。我的意思是，有趣的是，许多城市规划者长期以来一直想要这个，无论是否有疫情。他们只是想看到街道被用于除驾驶以外的其他目的。没错。我们在节目中经常谈论这个。我问瑞安·鲁索，这项政策是否是他为城市制定的更大交通愿景的一部分。
What we're doing now is focused on helping Oakland at this moment, and that is number one. That said, we're learning. We can't help but learn from observing how that's going. And while we're taking quick action, we're not doing something that's particularly expensive or permanent. So if it's not working, it's quite easy to pick up the barricades with the sign strap to them and adjust what we're doing. Yeah. Is there any way that any chance that you know when this is all over some of the streets might stay slow streets? I mean, I think that with the work we're doing on Oakland Solosaries, we're focused on keeping people safe. Now, I do think it's a great experiment and as we hear from our communities,
我们现在所做的是专注于帮助奥克兰度过这一刻，这是第一位的。话虽如此，我们正在学习。我们无法不从观察进展中学习。虽然我们采取了快速行动，但我们并没有做特别昂贵或永久的事情。所以如果行不通，很容易把绑着标志的路障移走，调整我们的做法。是的。有没有可能，你知道，当这一切结束后，一些街道可能会保持慢行街道的状态？我的意思是，我认为通过我们在奥克兰慢行街道上所做的工作，我们专注于保障人们的安全。现在，我确实认为这是一个伟大的实验，当我们听到社区的声音时，
like, hey, that was working or that wasn't, we're gonna have our ear to the ground for that and we'll respond accordingly. That sounds like a definite maybe. Yeah, I think we got a maybe. But I wanted to talk with an urbanist about this. And so I called up Allison Arieth. She's the editorial director
比如，嘿，那个行得通，或者那个行不通，我们会密切关注并做出相应的反应。听起来像是一个肯定的“也许”。是的，我想我们得到了一个“也许”。但我还是想和一位城市规划者谈谈这件事。所以我打电话给了艾莉森·阿里斯。她是交通智库Spur的编辑总监，
for the transportation think tank spur. And she said she's really encouraged by what's happening in Oakland. I think what this has shown is one, you can do these really fast. Just put up a bunch of cones and then you have a bike lane. Instead of having a hundred committee meetings over how horrible this is going to be and no one's going to use them and all the other evidence that people make, like just do it. And yeah, it will come to light that like, you know what, this street didn't make the most sense, but this one's really working and
她说她对奥克兰正在发生的事情感到非常鼓舞。我认为这表明了第一，你可以很快地做到这些。只要放上一堆锥筒，你就拥有了一条自行车道。而不是就这有多糟糕、没人会用它们以及人们编造的所有其他证据进行一百次委员会会议，直接做就行了。是的，事实会证明，你知道，这条街可能不太合适，但那条街真的很有效，而且
the only way to do it is try and to just be able to like throw something on the ground is great. And she says that throughout history, moments of crisis have also been moments of experimentation inside cities, chances for cities to try things out, try to make themselves better, more livable. Right. I mean, it took Chicago burning to the ground to totally remake the grid of Chicago. And even more akin to what's happening now, Central Park in New York came about partially as a reaction to the cholera epidemics of the 19th century.
唯一的方法就是尝试，能够把东西放在地上真是太好了。她说，纵观历史，危机时刻也是城市内部的实验时刻，是城市尝试新事物、努力让自己变得更好、更宜居的机会。没错。我的意思是，芝加哥被烧毁才彻底重塑了芝加哥的网格。甚至更类似于现在正在发生的事情，纽约中央公园的出现部分是对19世纪霍乱流行的一种反应。
We need more space for people to be and exist. Yeah. And even more recently, just look at the last recession, which was obviously terrible for cities, but it also gave rise to all these tactical urbanism projects in cities like San Francisco. That's why we have all these parklets. And that's why we have the proxy shipping container project that used a lot that no one could afford to develop
我们需要更多的空间让人存在和生活。是的。甚至更近一点，看看上次经济衰退，这对城市来说显然很糟糕，但它也促成了旧金山等城市的所有这些战术城市主义项目。这就是为什么我们有所有这些小型公园。这就是为什么我们有那个利用没人买得起的土地的临时集装箱项目，
and turned it into the great public space. That stuff has stayed around. Some cities around the world are already planning to use this crisis as a chance to remake themselves. Milan, just announced that they would use this summer to transform over 20 miles of streets into spaces for pedestrians and bicyclists. Allison has hoped that in Oakland and elsewhere in this country,
并把它变成了伟大的公共空间。那些东西留了下来。世界上一些城市已经在计划利用这场危机作为重塑自身的机会。米兰刚刚宣布，他们将利用这个夏天将超过20英里的街道改造成行人和骑自行车者的空间。艾莉森希望在奥克兰和这个国家的其他地方，
maybe some of these experiments in traffic reduction might stick. I think people are still figuring it out, but ultimately I think this is a huge indicator of how much more space we could give to the public. And, you know, I'm not going to say like, oh, there will be no cars in our post-COVID future, but hopefully people will understand, wow, it actually feels quite liberating to walk down the middle of the street. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, and Joe Rosenberg. Mixing tech production by Sriviusi, music by Sean Rial.
也许其中一些减少交通的实验可能会持续下去。我认为人们仍在摸索，但最终我认为这是一个巨大的指标，表明我们可以给公众提供多少更多的空间。而且，你知道，我不会说，哦，我们后疫情时代的未来将没有汽车，但希望人们会明白，哇，走在马路中间确实感觉很自由。本周的《99%隐形》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德莱尼·霍尔和乔·罗森伯格制作。混音技术制作由斯里维西负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。
Katie Mingle is the senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the crew is Chris Barube, Sophia Klatsker, Vivian Leigh, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Ragu Karnad, whose piece in the New Yorker inspired our segment on air pollution in India. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is distributed in multiple locations around the East Bay, but in our heart will always be in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
凯蒂·明格尔是高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。其余工作人员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克、薇薇安·李和我罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢拉古·卡纳德，他在《纽约客》上的文章启发了我们关于印度空气污染的片段。我们是旧金山91.7KALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，在东湾的多个地点分发，但我们的心将永远在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的骄傲成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性的听众支持的播客组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到他们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI-O-R. We're on Instagram and read it too. But you can learn more about all the research we talked about today atepi.org Radio Tepi from PRX you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI-O-R。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。但你可以在epi.org上了解更多关于我们今天讨论的所有研究。来自PRX的Radio Tepi。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。